Narrator: TONIGHT ON A SPECIAL
"SHARK TANK"...
WE HONOR AMERICA'S
HEROIC VETERANS.
MAJOR MOM IS HERE
TO SAVE THE DAY.
Narrator:
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
WE KNOW THAT BUSINESSES ARE MORE
POWERFUL THAN BULLETS.
OOH RAH.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS
HEAR A GREAT IDEA...
THAT'S AMAZING.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY
AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
200K FOR 25%.
SO, WE'RE SPLITTING IT
THREE WAYS.
NO.
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
THIS COMPANY IS SO MUCH MORE
THAN JUST A PRODUCT.
WHY IS IT WORTH $10 MILLION?
IN 15 MONTHS,
WE SOLD ABOUT 1,500 UNITS.
HOW MUCH DID YOU SPEND
UP TO THAT POINT?
IF I TOLD YOU,
I'D HAVE TO KILL YOU.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M LISA BRADLEY.
AND I'M CAMERON CRUSE.
AND WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF R. RIVETER.
CAMERON AND I ARE BOTH
MILITARY SPOUSES.
WE MET WHEN
WE WERE IN GEORGIA
WHILE OUR HUSBANDS WERE
STATIONED WITH THE ARMY.
BEING A MILITARY SPOUSE
CAN BE DIFFICULT.
YOU MOVE ON AVERAGE
EVERY 2.9 YEARS,
WHICH MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
TO FIND A JOB
OR BUILD A RéSUMé
TO BE PROUD OF.
-HEY, GUYS.
-HEY.
-GOOD MORNING.
A BIG PURPOSE BEHIND OUR COMPANY
IS EMPOWERING WOMEN.
AND ACTUALLY WE NAMED OUR
COMPANY AFTER ROSIE THE RIVETER.
SHE'S A WORLD WAR II ICON
THAT ENCOURAGED WOMEN
TO GO BACK
INTO THE WORKFORCE
WHILE OUR MEN WERE SENT OFF
TO BATTLE.
HER MOTTO IS,
"WE CAN DO IT,"
AND THAT'S HOW WE FEEL
ABOUT OUR BUSINESS, TOO.
WE'RE SO EXCITED
TO GET THIS OUT TO YOU.
UP UNTIL THIS POINT,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GROW
AND SCALE THIS COMPANY
BY OURSELVES.
BUT WE ARE
AT A TURNING POINT,
WHERE WE NEED
NOT ONLY CAPITAL
BUT EXPERTISE TO GET US
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
GETTING A DEAL
FROM THE SHARKS
MEANS THAT WE'D BE ABLE
TO SECURE THOSE JOBS
AND VALIDATE THEIR HARD WORK
AND DEDICATION TO THIS COUNTRY.
HI. I'M CAMERON CRUSE.
AND I'M LISA BRADLEY.
AND WE'RE THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF R. RIVETER,
A HANDBAG COMPANY
ON A MISSION.
WE ARE HERE
SEEKING $100,000
FOR A 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
AS MILITARY SPOUSES,
ONE OF THE TOUGHEST ASPECTS
IS UNCERTAINTY.
WHETHER THAT MEANS A DEPLOYMENT
OR RELOCATION,
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE JUST
OUT OF YOUR CONTROL.
BECAUSE OF THIS, WE HAVE SET OUT
ON A MISSION
TO EMPOWER AND CREATE MOBILE
INCOME FOR MILITARY SPOUSES.
OUR HANDBAGS ARE MADE FROM
UPCYCLED MILITARY MATERIALS
LIKE WOOL BLANKETS,
UNIFORMS, AND TENTS.
EACH R. RIVETER HANDBAG
TELLS A STORY.
LEATHER AND CANVAS IS CUT,
LINERS ARE SEWN
ALL AT THE HANDS OF OUR NATION'S
MILITARY SPOUSES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
R. RIVETER IS ABOUT
EMPOWERING MILITARY SPOUSES
AND REDEFINING THE BOUNDARIES
OF AMERICAN MANUFACTURING.
SO, SHARKS, WHO WILL HELP US
GROW THIS COMPANY
DEDICATED TO SERVING THE
FAMILIES WHO SERVE US ALL?
WE'VE GOT SOME BAGS
WE'D LIKE TO PASS OUT.
ROBERT,
WE'LL START WITH YOU.
THAT IS
THE FINCH MESSENGER.
15 MILITARY SPOUSES WENT
INTO MAKING THAT BAG.
THANK YOU.
LORI,
THE MRS. OTTO FOR YOU.
THAT BAG TRAVELED
OVER 3,000 MILES
ON ITS HANDMADE JOURNEY.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN AND DAYMOND, YOU GET TWO
OF OUR BESTSELLERS,
THE FINCH AND THE PATTON,
BOTH MADE FROM AN UPCYCLED
MILITARY TENT.
AND, MARK, YOURS IS MADE
FROM THE DRESS BLUE PANT
OF A FIRST LIEUTENANT
IN THE ARMY.
THAT'S COOL.
SO, CAMERON, YOU SAID 15 PEOPLE
WENT INTO MAKING THIS.
Cruse: YES. SO, MILITARY SPOUSES
MOVE ON EVERY 2.9 YEARS,
AND THAT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT
TO FIND EMPLOYMENT,
PUT DOWN ROOTS, AND HAVE
A COMMUNITY TO BE A PART OF.
SO, WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS WE'VE
PROVIDED THE MOBILE EMPLOYMENT.
SO, MILITARY SPOUSES
MAKE THE PARTS AND PIECES.
LIKE THE "SUPPORT" TAG WAS DYED
IN COLORADO,
THE LEATHER WAS CUT
IN GEORGIA,
AND THE LINER WAS MADE
IN NEW YORK, AT FORT DRUM.
ALL THOSE PIECES COME TOGETHER
IN OUR SHOP IN NORTH CAROLINA,
JUST OUTSIDE
OF FORT BRAGG.
SO THEY ALL MAKE PARTS,
THEY SHIP IT TO YOU...
AND WE ASSEMBLE AND READY
FOR RETAIL.
AND SO WHAT'S THE TOTAL COST
OF THIS BAG,
FOR YOU TO MAKE IT,
WITH EVERYTHING IN?
$55 FOR THAT MRS. FINCH,
AND WE SELL IT FOR $220.
AND WHERE DO YOU TRACK
THE STORY?
SO IF I WANTED TO KNOW
THE STORY OF MY BAG...
ALL OF THE PARTS AND PIECES
MADE BY EACH MILITARY SPOUSE
ARE ACTUALLY STAMPED
WITH THEIR I.D.
Bradley: YOU CAN GO AROUND,
AND YOU CAN FIND
THE INDIVIDUAL STAMP
OF EVERY MILITARY SPOUSE
THAT PUT TIME AND EFFORT
INTO YOUR HANDBAG.
Herjavec:
AND SO I GUESS ONE RIVETER
WOULD HAVE MADE PORTIONS
OF EVERY BAG.
CORRECT.
IS THAT RIGHT?
Bradley: EXACTLY. RIGHT.
EACH VENDOR STARTS
WITH HER PART,
IN WHATEVER
SHE'S PROFICIENT IN,
AND SHE TAKES HER JOB WITH HER
WHEREVER SHE GOES.
SO THAT JOB IS GONNA
TRANSFER EVERYWHERE.
IS IT MOSTLY MILITARY PERSONNEL
BUYING THEM?
A LOT OF IT IS.
RIGHT NOW OUR TARGET MARKET
CONSISTS LARGELY OF
THE MILITARY SUPPORTER,
BUT SOMEBODY
WHO REALLY UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE POWER OF THEIR DOLLAR
IS INVESTING IN A COMMUNITY.
HOW -- HOW ARE YOU -- HOW ARE
YOU REACHING OUT TO THEM?
HOW THEY BUYING THEM?
RIGHT NOW WE'RE SELLING
60% ONLINE
AND 40% IN OUR
BRICK-AND-MORTAR STORE.
CAMERON, WHAT ARE THE SALES?
ALMOST $300,000
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS,
$190,000 YEAR TO DATE.
WOW. THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
IF WE GET AN INVESTMENT,
WE'RE EXPECTING $400,000
THIS YEAR.
WHY? WHAT WILL
THE INVESTMENT DO
TO ACTUALLY CHANGE YOUR SALES
BY 25%?
WE BELIEVE THAT,
WITH AN INVESTMENT,
WE CAN ACTUALLY PUT MONEY
INTO MARKETING.
WE'VE ONLY PUT
$2,000 IN EACH.
MY DAD PUT $5,000 IN.
OTHER THAN THAT, WE'VE GROWN
THE COMPANY DOLLAR BY DOLLAR.
SO YOU'VE INVESTED A TOTAL
OF $9,000.
YES.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
Herjavec:
LISA, TELL US YOUR STORY.
TELL US YOUR BACKGROUND.
TELL US HOW YOU GOT TOGETHER.
WELL,
WHEN I MET MY HUSBAND,
IT WAS REALLY THE BEGINNING
OF THE END OF MY CAREER.
I ACTUALLY MADE FOUR
CROSS-COUNTRY MOVES
BY THE TIME I WAS 24.
WOW.
I DID GO
TO BUSINESS SCHOOL,
BUT I DIDN'T GET TO START
MY CAREER.
WE ACTUALLY MOVED TO GEORGIA,
AND THAT'S WHERE I MET CAMERON.
OUR HUSBANDS WERE
RANGER INSTRUCTORS.
YOUR HUSBANDS ARE RANGERS?
YES.
WOW. VERY IMPRESSIVE.
AND THEN I HAVE A MASTER'S
IN ARCHITECTURE.
GUYS, MOST --
MOST OF YOUR SALES --
60% OF YOUR SALES ARE ONLINE,
RIGHT?
YES.
YES, ABSOLUTELY.
SO, TELL US ABOUT YOUR WEBSITE,
INCREASING YOUR TRAFFIC.
SO, ALL OF OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE SAYING
THAT THEY'RE FINDING US
FROM SOME KIND OF NEWS MEDIA
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
OR WORD OF MOUTH.
SO, HUGE, UNTAPPED MARKET
FOR US ONLINE.
WE SEE A HUGE
POTENTIAL THERE,
AND PART OF THE INVESTMENT
TODAY WOULD BE
TO HOPEFULLY GO TOWARDS THAT
AND -- AND GROW THAT.
ARE YOU GETTING ANY PUSHBACK
ON THE PRICE OF THESE BAGS?
'CAUSE THEY ARE
PREMIUM-PRICED.
I THINK OUR TARGET MARKET
UNDERSTANDS WHAT IT MEANS
TO MAKE SOMETHING IN AMERICA
AND SELL IT
AND BE ABLE TO MAKE MONEY
AND HELP MORE MILITARY SPOUSES.
SO, DO YOU
SEND THEM TEMPLATES?
YES.
FOR EXAMPLE, LIKE,
"THIS MAKES THIS BAG."
DO THEY HAVE A BOOK OF ALL
THE DIFFERENT STYLES?
THEY DO.
YES, ABSOLUTELY.
SO, WE TELL THEM HOW WE ACCEPT
THE PIECES,
WHAT WE'RE GONNA BUY
FROM THEM,
AND THEY MAKE IT
TO OUR STANDARD.
I THINK THE BEAUTIFUL
THING ABOUT OUR HANDBAGS
IS THE SIMPLICITY OF THEM.
A MILITARY SPOUSE
CAN COME IN
WITH NO SEWING EXPERIENCE
AND LEARN HOW.
Cuban: WHAT'S REALLY, REALLY
COOL TO ME IS,
YOU ARE A SOCIAL NETWORK
THROUGH ACTION, RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU COULD BE LITERALLY
THE FUTURE OF --
OF MANUFACTURING,
IN SOME RESPECTS,
FOR SPECIALTY MANUFACTURING.
EVERYBODY WHO CONTRIBUTES HAS
PRIDE OF OWNERSHIP, RIGHT?
SO THEY BECOME A SALES REP
WITHOUT HAVING TO ACTUALLY
SELL THE BAG, RIGHT?
"I HELPED BUILD THIS," RIGHT?
YEAH.
WHEN YOU START GETTING
THAT PERSONAL CONNECTION,
IT COULD TAKE IT
TO A WHOLE NOTHER LEVEL.
Herjavec:
I LOVE THE BUSINESS.
I GET A SENSE THAT THIS IS MORE
THAN JUST A BUSINESS FOR YOU.
THIS COMPANY IS SO MUCH MORE
THAN JUST A PRODUCT.
WE'RE STANDING UP HERE
FOR EVERY MILITARY SPOUSE
THAT'S EVER HAD A DREAM.
AND SO HAVE A LOT RIDING
ON OUR SHOULDERS.
SO, TODAY WE JUST WANTED TO COME
HERE AND TELL OUR STORY
AND -- AND TELL YOU
THAT MILITARY SPOUSES --
ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
WEARING THE UNIFORM,
THEY'RE SERVING
IN THEIR OWN WAY.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE AT
HOME, MAKING SURE THAT THEY --
THAT THE SOLDIERS HAVE A FAMILY
TO COME HOME TO.
YOU KNOW, IT'S EXTREME COURAGE
AND SACRIFICE
TO BE A MILITARY WIFE.
SOMETIMES IT IS.
WHY DO YOU FEEL
YOU NEED A PARTNER?
I THINK THAT YOU GUYS
ARE REALLY ONTO SOMETHING.
MANUFACTURING, MAKING AND
RETAILING IN THE UNITED STATES,
IS -- IT'S GONNA BE
A HARD BUSINESS.
I THINK WE NEED
A STRATEGIC PARTNER
AND SOMEBODY WHO CAN HELP US
GET TO THAT LEVEL
WHERE WE CAN INCREASE
THE DEMAND STEADILY.
IF I GAVE YOU THE MONEY,
TELL ME HOW YOU WOULD SPEND IT.
WE COULD START IMMEDIATELY
WITH BASIC ONLINE STRATEGIES,
LIKE PAY-PER-CLICK ADVERTISING,
CONTENT MARKETING,
JUST BASICS.
SCALING THE COMPANY SMARTLY
IS PARAMOUNT.
WE PLANNED OUT FOR,
IF WE SOLD $1 MILLION,
THAT WE COULD FULFILL THAT
WITH 30 OPERATORS
IN THE NEW SPACE
THAT WE HAVE.
IT WOULD TAKE US THREE MONTHS
OF PRODUCTION.
OKAY. SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE --
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A LEAD TIME --
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SAY THAT
IT'S A 90-DAY LEAD TIME TO GET
YOUR PRODUCT TO DELIVER.
BUT I DON'T THINK IN THIS CASE
THAT'S A PROBLEM, MARK.
THE 90 DAYS WOULD BE BECAUSE
WE NEED TO HIRE PEOPLE.
IT'S JUST HIRING THE PEOPLE,
TRAINING THEM UP,
AND STARTING PRODUCTION.
WHEN YOU -- WHEN YOU END UP
MAKING MONEY,
YOU BELIEVE THAT MAYBE
SOMEBODY ELSE
CAN DO SOMETHING BETTER
THAN YOU CAN.
AND YOU GO IN,
OFFER SOMEBODY 1/3 POTENTIALLY
OF YOUR COMPANY.
THEN YOU FIND OUT THAT THEY ARE
NO BETTER THAN YOU
AND THEY DON'T KNOW YOUR
BUSINESS AS WELL AS YOU DO.
AND NOW YOU'VE GIVEN
THAT PERCENTAGE
TO SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT DIDN'T EARN IT.
I DON'T KNOW
WHERE I WOULD ADD VALUE.
PURELY JUST MONEY --
YOU JUST DON'T NEED THAT.
YOU'RE MAKING IT.
SO I THINK THAT YOU CAN DO THIS
WITHOUT ME.
AT THIS STAGE,
FOR AN INVESTMENT,
IT'S NOT IN YOUR BEST INTEREST,
SO I'M OUT.
Narrator:
ONE SHARK IS OUT.
LISA AND CAMERON
HAVE FOUR MORE CHANCES
FOR A DEAL FOR THEIR COMPANY,
R. RIVETER --
A BAG LINE MADE BY
MILITARY SPOUSES.
I LIKE IT.
IT FITS KIND OF WHAT I'M DOING
IN TWO OTHER BUSINESSES.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $100,000.
YOU WANTED 10 --
YOU WANT TO SELL 10%?
-20%.
O'Leary: UM, OKAY.
BUT I-I DON'T WANT --
HE JUST WANTS TO GIVE YOU
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR.
I DON'T WANT TO PART-- I DON'T
WANT TO PARTNER WITH ANYBODY.
THAT'S IT.
I KNOW IT HAS TO BE DONE.
OUT OF RESPECT
FOR THE OTHER SHARKS,
CAN WE HEAR
WHAT THEY HAVE TO SAY?
I-I LOVE THE STORY.
MORE SO, I LOVE THE PRODUCT
AND I LOVE THE BUSINESS.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER --
$100,000 FOR 20%,
SAME OFFER THAT KEVIN MADE.
Cuban: I'M HAPPY TO MAKE
AN OFFER, AS WELL.
I'LL GIVE YOU YOUR $100,000
FOR 20%, RIGHT?
BUT WHAT I'LL ALSO DO IS PROVIDE
WHATEVER CREDIT YOU NEED
FOR THE INVENTORY.
AND IF WE NEED
EXTRA EQUIPMENT,
I HAVE NO PROBLEM PROVIDING
THE CREDIT FOR THAT.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
UM, WELL...
THANK YOU
FOR YOUR OFFERS.
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW
IF I COULD DO WHAT YOU DO.
MY MOTTO --
WHAT I'VE ALWAYS DONE IS
I MAKE THINGS FOR MASS,
RIGHT?
YOU'RE DOING A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT MODEL
THAN WHAT I'M USED TO.
I ADMIRE AND RESPECT IT,
AND I THINK IT'S GREAT.
I WISH YOU LUCK,
BUT I'M OUT.
John: LORI AND I ARE BOTH OUT
FOR THE SAME REASONS.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU SHOULD
TELL ALL THREE OF THESE BOBOS
TO TAKE A WALK AND KEEP THE REST
OF YOUR COMPANY,
AND YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
THAT'S USEFUL.
John: BUT NOW YOU HAVE
THREE OFFERS.
OKAY.
MARK, YOU HAVE A DEAL.
AH!
YES!
-[ CHUCKLES ]
-GOOD.
GOOD TO DO BUSINESS WITH YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU, LISA.
THANK YOU.
-GOOD JOB, LADIES.
-THANK YOU GUYS.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-THANK YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
Grenier: CONGRATULATIONS.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS GREAT.
THANK YOU.
WE APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
THEY DIDN'T NEED THE HELP.
DAYMOND...
THEY DID.
...IF THEY WALKED OUT BECAUSE
THE REST OF US SAID NO,
YOU WOULD HAVE RUN DOWN,
GRABBED THEM, AND SAID,
"I'LL HELP YOU."
SO?
I'M JUST SAYING.
Grenier: [ LAUGHS ]
Bradley: WE HAD SO MUCH
ON OUR SHOULDERS,
REPRESENTING EVERY
MILITARY SPOUSE
THAT'S WANTED SOMETHING MORE
THAN A PART-TIME JOB.
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN GROW
THIS COMPANY
AND HELP AS MANY MILITARY
SPOUSES AS POSSIBLE.
WE HOPE THAT WE INSPIRE
OTHER MILITARY SPOUSES
TO DO WHAT THEY LOVE
AND ASPIRE TO REACH THEIR GOALS,
DREAMS, AND PASSIONS.
Narrator: IN SEASON SIX,
WE WATCHED AIR FORCE VETERAN
KRISTINA GUERRERO
MAKE A DEAL WITH DAYMOND JOHN
FOR HER TurboPUP,
A MEAL-ON-THE-GO BAR FOR DOGS.
John: I'LL GO $100,000
FOR 40%.
-35%?
-YOU GOT IT.
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
KRISTINA!
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
DAYMOND,
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU!
John: I'M IN PHOENIX TODAY
WITH KRISTINA FROM TurboPUP
FOR A BIG MEETING
AT PetSmart HEADQUARTERS.
YOU LOOK DIFFERENT.
WHEN ARE YOU DUE?
NEXT MONTH.
AH. WELL,
WE BETTER HURRY UP.
YOU WANT TO MEET
THE PetSmart GUYS?
YES!
John: WHEN I FIRST SAW
KRISTINA PITCH,
IT JUST HIT ME -- THERE IS NO
CATEGORY FOR CANINE MEAL BARS.
I HAVE TWO DOGS THAT I LOVE,
AND I SAW THERE WAS A NEED
FOR THE PRODUCT.
-ERAN.
-DAYMOND.
THANKS FOR HAVING US.
Guerrero:
AFTER "SHARK TANK,"
DAYMOND HELPED ME PARTNER UP
WITH A COMPANY CALLED
FETCH FOR PETS!,
A LEADING DISTRIBUTOR
IN THE PET INDUSTRY.
THEY WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN SETTING UP THIS AMAZING DEAL
WITH PetSmart.
THE IDEA OF A PORTABLE MEAL
SOLUTION -- AMAZING.
WE ARE PREPARED
TO PUT TurboPUP
IN MORE THAN 700 STORES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
700?!
WOW.
700.
Guerrero: UP UNTIL NOW,
WE'VE REALLY ONLY BEEN
AVAILABLE ONLINE,
AND IT'S REALLY LIMITED
OUR SALES.
BUT NOW TURBOPUPS EVERYWHERE
CAN TRY OUR BARS
AND FALL IN LOVE WITH IT,
JUST LIKE MY OWN TURBOPUPS HAVE.
-NICE.
-WOW.
THIS IS WHERE EVERYTHING
IS MERCHANDISED
BEFORE IT GOES
TO A REAL STORE.
John: THIS IS A HUGE FIRST STEP
FOR TurboPUP,
AND WE HAVE SPEED TO MARKET.
AND ONCE YOU HAVE
SPEED TO MARKET,
GREAT DISTRIBUTION,
AND AN AMAZING PRODUCT,
THE SKY'S THE LIMIT.
Cohen: IS THIS NOT FABULOUS?
THIS IS AMAZING.
Guerrero:
I'D ONLY BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR A YEAR AND A HALF,
WITH ONLY $11,000 IN SALES.
IT'S BEEN A LITTLE LESS
THAN A YEAR
SINCE I MADE MY DEAL
WITH DAYMOND,
AND WE HAVE OVER $200,000
IN SALES.
I THINK THIS DEAL WITH PetSmart
IS GONNA PUSH US TO OVER
$1 MILLION IN SALES.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND,
FOR MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
OH, THANK YOU.
Guerrero: WHEN I HUNG UP
MY FLIGHT SUIT,
I DECIDED TO START A BUSINESS,
AND IT'S CHANGED MY LIFE.
"SHARK TANK" REALLY RECOGNIZES
THAT VETERANS HAVE SO MUCH TO
BRING TO THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY,
AND IT'S BROUGHT SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO TurboPUP.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A HIGH-TECH WAY
TO HAVE CONTROL RIGHT
AT YOUR FINGERTIPS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS TARIK RODGERS
FROM DALLAS, TEXAS.
WHAT!
THAT'S RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND I AM THE C.E.O.
OF BEARTEK.
AND MY NAME IS WILLIE BLOUNT
FROM COLUMBIA, MARYLAND.
I AM THE FOUNDER
OF BEARTEK.
WE ARE HERE
SEEKING $500,000
FOR 5% INTEREST
IN OUR COMPANY.
WHOA.
-WHAT?!
-WHAT?
SHARKS,
WE LOVE THE OUTDOORS,
AND NOTHING IS BETTER THAN
HOPPING ON MY MOTORCYCLE
AND TAKING A LONG RIDE.
PROBLEM IS, WHENEVER I WANT
TO LISTEN TO MUSIC,
IT'S NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
AND DANGEROUS
TO REACH FOR MY PHONE
TO PLAY A SONG.
AND ME -- AS A SKIER,
I WEAR GLOVES ALL THE TIME,
AND I RUN INTO THE EXACT
SAME PROBLEMS.
BEARTEK TRANSFORMS ANY GLOVE
INTO THE MOST CONVENIENT,
SAFE, AND ACCURATE
REMOTE CONTROL IMAGINABLE.
NOW YOUR SMARTPHONE IS ALWAYS
RIGHT AT YOUR FINGERTIPS.
SO, SHARKS, LET ME JUST GET YOU
TO DO ME A FAVOR.
RAISE YOUR HANDS FOR ME.
NOW GO AHEAD
AND TAP YOUR THUMB
AND YOUR INDEX FINGER
TOGETHER.
[ MID-TEMPO
GUITAR MUSIC PLAYING ]
NOW GO AHEAD AND TAP ANOTHER ONE
'CAUSE THAT'S NOT MY SONG.
[ ELECTRIC GUITAR MUSIC
PLAYING ]
NO, THAT'S NOT MINE, EITHER.
LET'S GIVE IT ONE MORE.
[ FUNKY MUSIC PLAYS ]
THERE WE GO.
GIVE ME A TAP FOR SOME VOLUME.
LET'S JAM OUT NOW.
[ VOLUME INCREASES ]
ALL RIGHT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WITH THIS TECHNOLOGY,
NOW YOU CAN KEEP YOUR EYES
ON THE ROAD AND THE SLOPES.
BUT MUSIC
IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
NOW IT IS JUST THAT EASY TO
CONTROL ANY DEVICE IMAGINABLE,
FROM CONSUMER-ACTION CAMERAS
TO MILITARY-GRADE EQUIPMENT.
THE POSSIBILITIES
ARE ENDLESS.
IT IS OUR VISION THAT ALL GLOVES
WILL BE POWERED BY BEARTEK.
WE ARE NOT JUST A PRODUCT.
WE ARE A TECH COMPANY.
AND, SHARKS, WITH YOUR HELP,
WE COULD BECOME A TECH EMPIRE.
NOW, WHO'S READY TO BE...
Both:
...POWERED BY BEARTEK?
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREAT PRESENTATION, GUYS.
THANK YOU.
SHARKS,
TARIK WILL HAND OUT SOME GLOVES
TO YOU ALL,
AND I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
HOW THEY WORK.
HERE YOU GO.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
FOR THE RIDER.
THERE YOU GO.
FOR YOU.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S THE NICE
SMALL SIZE THERE.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
BEARTEK PACKAGING.
AND WITH YOU HERE --
YOU CAN PASS THIS OUT.
THIS IS THE MODULE
THAT'S INSIDE.
THIS IS THE BRAINS.
GOT IT.
SO, SHARKS, EVERY
"POWERED BY BEARTEK" GLOVE
HAS SIX TOUCH POINTS.
EACH TOUCH POINT HAS --
RECEIVES A DIFFERENT COMMAND
AND CAUSES THE BEHAVIOR
THAT YOU SEEK.
THE THUMB IS YOUR ACTIVATION
TOUCH POINT.
SO, THE ACT OF TOUCHING
YOUR THUMB
TO ANY OF THESE SIX TOUCH POINTS
CAUSES AN ACTION.
AS WAS DEMONSTRATED EARLIER,
VOLUME UP,
VOLUME DOWN,
NEXT AND PREVIOUS SONG,
ANSWER/REJECT CALLS,
OR START AND STOP YOUR MUSIC.
ON THE BACK OF EVERY GLOVE
IS A POCKET.
IN THAT POCKET IS WHERE THE
BEARTEK SYNC MODULE GOES.
YOU PLUG THAT INTO THE GLOVE,
AND YOU'RE OFF TO THE RACES.
SO, TELL ME
WHERE YOU'RE AT NOW.
SO, WE CREATED THE MODULE,
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
ITERATIONS OF THIS GLOVE.
SO YOU'RE ONLY SELLING GLOVES
RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE SELLING GLOVES
AND MODULES.
HOWEVER,
OUR LONG-TERM PLAY
IS NOT TO BE IN THE
GLOVE-SELLING BUSINESS.
HERE WE GO.
WE ARE NOT IN THE BUSINESS
OF SELLING GLOVES.
WE LAUNCHED
BEARTEK GLOVES
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PROVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY.
WELL, YOU ARE IN THE BUSINESS
OF SELLING GLOVES TODAY,
BUT YOU'RE ONLY DOING IT
TO PROVE THE CONCEPT.
THIS IS YOUR PROOF
OF CONCEPT, YEAH.
-SO, WHAT WE DID WAS, IN --
-SO -- SO --
IN THE BEGINNING OF 2013,
WE ACTUALLY LAUN--
WE WENT TO A BUNCH
OF TRADE SHOWS.
GOT LOTS OF BRANDS
THAT WANTED
TO HAVE THIS POWER
IN THEIR GLOVES.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS, WE REALIZED
IT TAKES THEM TWO YEARS
TO GO AHEAD, DESIGN,
DEVELOP IN THEIR --
THE DEVELOPMENT LIFE CYCLE.
SO WE SAID,
"WE CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT."
SO, IN FIVE MONTHS,
WE DID WHAT THESE COMPANIES
SAID IT WOULD TAKE THEM
TO DO TWO YEARS...
AND IN FIVE MONTHS --
AND HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
IN 15 MONTHS, WE DID A PILOT,
AND WE SOLD ABOUT 1,500 UNITS.
WHAT DO THEY COST?
THEY GO BETWEEN
$200 AND $275.
-DAMN!
-AND YOUR TOTAL SALES --
-IT'S ALL ABOUT THE GLOVE.
-$275?
DAMN!
WE SOLD $200,000 WORTH OF GLOVES
IN ABOUT 15 MONTHS.
SO, GUYS, HOW'D YOU TWO
START WORKING TOGETHER?
WHAT'S YOUR BACKGROUNDS?
WE'RE COUSINS,
SECOND COUSINS.
I WENT INTO
THE MARINE CORPS
AND STUDIED AVIATION
ELECTRONICS.
I WAS RIDING FOREVER,
AND I'VE ALWAYS HAD THE PROBLEM
OF CONTROLLING MY MUSIC.
AND, YOU KNOW, IN THE MARINES,
THERE'S THIS MANTRA WE HAVE.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM,
YOU IMPROVISE, ADAPT,
AND OVERCOME...
ABSOLUTELY.
...THAT PROBLEM.
SO I CALLED TARIK,
AND HE WAS --
AS SOON AS I TALKED TO HIM
ABOUT IT, HE WAS LIKE, "I'M IN,"
BECAUSE HE ACTUALLY
HAD THE PROBLEM
THAT THIS WOULD HAVE SOLVED
WHILE HE WAS OUT ON THE SLOPES.
SO, AFTER THAT,
WE GOT TOGETHER.
MY TECHNICAL BACKGROUND
AND HIS BUSINESS BACKGROUND --
TARIK, HOW MUCH MONEY
DID YOU PUT IN?
I'VE PUT IN $500,000.
OH!
WOW!
WHERE DID YOU
GET THE $500,000?
I'VE HAD A LOT OF CAREER
IN FORTUNE 500 COMPANIES,
BUT THE LAST 7 YEARS
OF MY CAREER
HAVE ALL BEEN
IN START-UPS.
BUT YOU HAD THE CASH.
SO WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE
MONEY OUT OF OUR POCKET
AND PUT IT IN THERE.
HOW -- WHY IS IT WORTH
$10 MILLION?
I STILL HAVEN'T HEARD THAT.
OKAY, SO, ALL WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT NOW -- CONSUMER SPACE.
OKAY.
WHAT WE ALSO HAVE GOING ON
AT THIS VERY MOMENT --
MILITARY COMPANIES STARTED
COMING TO US, SAYING,
"HEY, WE WANT TO CONTROL
HEADS-UP DISPLAYS,
NIGHT-VISION GOGGLES,
COMPUTER-AIDED SCOPES.
WITH GLOVES.
THE POINT IS, OUR MARKET ARE
PEOPLE THAT WEAR GLOVES.
ONCE YOU PUT GLOVES ON,
IT INHIBITS YOU
FROM BEING ABLE TO CONTROL
YOUR TECHNOLOGY.
OKAY. I GOT YOU.
HERE'S WHAT I'M EXPECTING YOU
TO SAY.
FOR A $10-MILLION VALUATION,
I'M EXPECTING YOU
TO GO BEYOND GLOVES
'CAUSE I GOT TO TELL YOU,
I'M NOT SUPER EXCITED
ABOUT GIVING YOU $500,000
FOR 5% FOR A GLOVE COMPANY.
I FEAR YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
A DEAL HERE TODAY.
IT'S NOT JUST
A GLOVE COMPANY, THOUGH.
EXACTLY RIGHT.
Herjavec: BUT THAT'S WHAT
I'M WAITING TO HEAR.
WHEN DO WE GO
BEYOND GLOVES?
SO, HERE'S THE THING --
I'VE BEEN PUSHING MY FINGERS
LIKE THIS FOR ABOUT 15 MINUTES,
TRYING TO HEAR WHY YOU'RE
WORTH $10 MILLION,
AND IT'S NOT WORKING.
Narrator:
ALL SHARKS ARE STILL IN,
BUT THEY QUESTION THE
$10-MILLION VALUATION
FOR WILLIE AND TARIK'S HIGH-TECH
GLOVE COMPANY, BEARTEK.
I'VE BEEN PUSHING MY FINGERS
LIKE THIS FOR ABOUT 15 MINUTES,
TRYING TO HEAR WHY
YOU'RE WORTH $10 MILLION,
AND IT'S NOT WORKING.
WE'RE PUTTING AN OPPORTUNITY
IN FRONT OF YOU
THAT IS GOING TO --
THAT IS GONNA GET TO
AT LEAST $32 MILLION.
WE HAVE MAJOR RETAILERS THAT ARE
STARTING TO CARRY THIS.
O'Leary: LET ME TAKE
A CRACK AT THIS.
I'M LOOKING AT IT THIS WAY.
NO ONE ELSE HAS BROUGHT IT UP,
BUT I MIGHT AS WELL.
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS TO
INTERFACE WITH DEVICES
THAT DON'T REQUIRE MANIPULATION
BY YOUR DIGITS, OKAY?
'CAUSE I'VE SEEN A HELMET NOW
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO SPEAK
TO A DEVICE
WHILE YOU'RE RIDING.
IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHETHER IT'S A CAR
OR WHETHER YOU'RE ON A BIKE
OR A BICYCLE.
-I'VE SEEN IT FOR...
-HOW ACCURATE IS IT?
Herjavec:
VERY ACCURATE.
WHAT'S YOUR GREATEST STRENGTH
AGAINST VOICE ACTIVATION?
ONE, YOU C-- YOU DON'T MAKE ANY
MISTAKES USING THIS PRODUCT
BECAUSE YOU KNOW PRECISELY WHERE
YOU'RE TOUCHING YOUR FINGER.
WITH VOICE ACTIVATION...
WELL, THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
...IT HAS HISTORICALLY HAPPENED
WHERE YOU TRY TO SAY SOMETHING
AND IT EITHER MISREADS YOU AND
IT UNDERSTANDS SOMETHING ELSE
AND THEN YOU GOT TO BACK OUT
OF THAT COMMAND SET
TO TRY TO GET BACK IN
AND SAY WHAT YOU WOULD
YOU LIKE IT TO SAY.
BUT THAT'S MORE IMPORTANT
IN INDUSTRIAL
THAN WHICH SONG YOU PICK.
-IT'S A NICHE APPLICATION.
-SURE, ABSOLUTELY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOUR OPTION
ISN'T A GOOD ONE.
IT COULD BE AN ALTERNATIVE.
IT MAY BE THAT THE MARKET'S
PASSED YOU BY.
I'M NOT GONNA STICK AROUND
TO FIND OUT.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: THE AMOUNT OF TIME
YOU HAVE TO WAIT
FOR THEM TO INTEGRATE
AND THEN SELL,
AND THEN YOU STILL HAVE
THAT ENTIRE RISK PROFILE
OF NOT KNOWING
IF THEY'LL SELL --
THE RISK/REWARD IS NOT THERE.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THERE'S
SOME MERIT HERE,
BUT HONESTLY, GUYS,
YOU'RE ASKING FOR
A $10-MILLION VALUATION.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE SAID MAYBE,
"I HAVE GOVERNMENT CONTRACTS,"
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
WE'RE NOT EVEN
IN THE SAME UNIVERSE.
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA PUT AN OFFER
OUT AT THAT PRICE,
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
GUYS, TO ME, WHAT I WAS HOPING
YOU WOULD SAY
WAS THAT THE GLOVE
WAS SIMPLY A --
A CARRIER FOR THE TECHNOLOGY,
BUT IT'S ONE OF MANY.
BUT EVERY TIME ANYBODY
ASKED YOU A QUESTION,
WE ALWAYS WENT BACK
TO THE GLOVE.
ROBERT,
IS THERE ANY VALUATION
THAT YOU WOULD GIVE
THESE GUYS $500,000?
WHAT PERCENTAGE
WOULD YOU NEED?
WILLIE, THERE ARE --
THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THIS COMPANY'S WORTH.
LOOK, HERE'S THE FIRST THING
I'LL TELL YOU --
IS THERE A NUMBER?
GOOD FOR YOU.
YOU'VE DEVELOPED
THE TECHNOLOGY.
BUT WHEN YOU COME IN WITH
A $10 MILLION VALUATION,
WE'RE GONNA TAKE IT
VERY SERIOUSLY.
I DON'T WANT TO BE IN THE GLOVE
BUSINESS FOR $10 MILLION.
-I-I --
-NEITHER DO WE.
WELL, BUT YOU
HAVEN'T SHOWN ME
HOW YOU'RE GONNA GET OUT
OF THE GLOVE BUSINESS.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
THE REASON WHY WE DON'T
WANT TO BE IN THE GLOVE
BUSINESS SO MUCH
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE LEARNED
FROM CONSUMERS,
THEY ARE VERY PARTICULAR
ABOUT THE GLOVES THEY WEAR.
SO WE CAN'T CARRY
A MILLION SKUs
ON A MILLION DIFFERENT KINDS OF
GLOVES TO MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY.
I LIKE YOU GUYS.
I THINK YOU'RE SMART.
I THINK IT IS A VERY CLEVER
APPLICATION.
I LIKE ANYTHING
THAT KEEPS YOU SAFER.
RIGHT.
SO I THINK YOU REALLY HAVE
SOMETHING HERE
THAT WILL BE APPEALING
TO THE CONSUMER
AND MAYBE TO THE ARMY AND --
AND EVERYBODY ELSE,
BUT YOU'RE JUST AT THIS POINT
OF FIGURING IT OUT.
YOU'RE NOT REALLY SURE YET.
MM-HMM.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
-THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
-ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
-ALL RIGHT, NOW.
-ALL RIGHT.
IF THERE'S EVER A DEAL THAT
TELLS YOU VALUATION MATTERS,
IT'S THIS ONE.
NO, NOT AT ALL,
NOT AT ALL.
ABSOLUTELY, MARK.
DOES IT? NO.
WHY DIDN'T YOU STEP UP
AND WRITE A CHECK?
I'M TELLING YOU
THAT THEY'LL --
THIS IS EXACTLY THE KIND OF
STUFF YOU LOVE TO DO.
IF -- IF THEY WOULD HAVE GIVEN
ME A PROOF OF CONCEPT --
BECAUSE YOU THINK IT'S A PIECE
OF CRAP.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A BUSINESS
THAT BRINGS MILITARY PRECISION
TO YOUR HOME.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS ANGELA CODY ROUGET,
AND I WAS A MAJOR IN
THE UNITED STATES AIR FORCE.
I'M SEEKING $150,000
FOR 20% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY,
MAJOR MOM.
I AM ON A MISSION TO COMBAT
CLUTTER AND DISORGANIZATION
IN HOMES ACROSS AMERICA.
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS CRAVE
MORE ORDER IN THEIR HOMES,
BUT MANY DON'T KNOW HOW
TO CREATE IT.
MY TEAM OF HIGHLY TRAINED
LIBERATORS
CAN PROFESSIONALLY ORGANIZE
EVERY ROOM IN YOUR HOME.
HERE ARE SOME "BEFORE"
AND "AFTER" PICTURES
OF SOME MISSIONS ACCOMPLISHED.
I SAVED THIS MARRIAGE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
THE WIFE'S CAR GOT BACK
IN THE GARAGE.
ALL THE HUSBAND'S STUFF
IS OUT OF THE WAY,
AND THEY LOVE EACH OTHER AGAIN
AND THEIR HOME.
THIS LITTLE GIRL CAN ACTUALLY
PLAY IN HER ROOM AGAIN.
ISN'T THAT SWEET?
AND NOW SHE'S ENJOYING HER HOME,
AND MAMA'S HAPPY.
SHARKS, MAJOR MOM
IS THE ONLY COMPANY
IN THE ORGANIZING-SERVICES
INDUSTRY
THAT EMBODIES MILITARY VALUES
AND TACTICS.
AS A MISSILE COMBAT
CREW COMMANDER,
I GAINED VALUABLE
ORGANIZING SKILLS,
SO MAJOR MOM IS HERE
TO SAVE THE DAY!
BUT I NEED YOUR HELP TO SCALE
OUR OPERATIONS.
IF THE PRESIDENT TRUSTED ME
WITH THE KEYS TO THE NUKES,
YOU CAN TRUST ME
WITH YOUR MONEY.
WHICH SHARK WANTS TO PARTNER
WITH ME TO COMBAT CLUTTER?
Grenier: I'M CURIOUS.
YOU SAID THAT YOU WERE
A MISSILE CREW COMMANDER.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT MEANT I HAD THE KEYS
TO MY NUKES.
MY ACTUAL HAND IS ON THE KEYS
THAT WOULD LAUNCH
INTERCONTINENTAL
BALLISTIC MISSILES
IN A FEW SECONDS.
GOOD. WHILE YOU'RE LAUGHING
AND ON THE PHONE.
THAT'S GOOD!
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: THE ACTUAL
NUCLEAR MISSILES?
THAT'S A -- A MISSILEER
CAN MULTITASK.
I'M TRAINED TO DO
75 TASKS AT ONCE
AND DO THEM ALL VERY WELL.
SO, WHAT'S THE -- WHAT'S
THE CLOSEST YOU CAME?
IF I TOLD YOU,
I'D HAVE TO KILL YOU.
THAT'S OKAY.
GO AHEAD! PLEASE!
PLEASE TELL US!
THAT'S OKAY.
SO, WHEN DID
YOU LEAVE SERVICE?
HOW LONG AGO?
-I LEFT THE SERVICE 10 --
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE,
BY THE WAY.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
I LEFT THE SERVICE 10 YEARS AGO.
AND WHAT -- WHAT MADE YOU
COME UP WITH THIS IDEA?
WELL, BASICALLY, WHEN I DECIDED
TO GET OUT OF THE MILITARY,
I WAS GONNA BE
A STAY-AT-HOME MOM.
AND UNFORTUNATELY, MY HUSBAND'S
REAL-ESTATE BUSINESS TANKED
LITERALLY SIX MONTHS AFTER
I RESIGNED MY COMMISSION.
SO HE SAID, "YOU'RE GONNA NEED
TO GO BACK TO WORK."
DID YOU NUKE HIM?
[ LAUGHS ]
I WANTED TO.
SO, ANYWAY...
I SAID, "OKAY, WELL,
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?"
AND HE SAID,
"YOU'RE SO ORGANIZED.
YOU LOVE TO DO IT.
YOU DO IT ALL THE TIME."
TELL US ABOUT THE BUSINESS.
WE ARE BASICALLY IN TWO STATES.
WE HAVE 16 EMPLOYEES.
SO, IN COLORADO AND PHOENIX,
ARIZONA,
WE HAVE BUILT THIS MODEL
OVER A SIX-YEAR PERIOD OF TIME.
WE TRAIN THEM HOW WE WANT THEM
TO ORGANIZE
WITH THE MAJOR MOM METHOD
OF ORGANIZING.
LORI KNOWS THAT, WITH
OUR ORGANIZING PRODUCTS,
IS YOU CAN'T
JUST BUY A PRODUCT.
THERE'S AN APPROACH
TO ORGANIZING.
HOW DOES IT WORK, ANGELA?
I CALL YOU UP.
OKAY. SO, WHEN YOU CALL US,
WE DO A FREE ESTIMATE
ON THE PHONE.
RANGE GOES FROM $288
FOR A JUMP START PACKAGE --
THAT'S 4 HOURS OF JUST A "GET IN
THERE AND GET 'EM STARTED" --
UP TO A LIBERTY PACKAGE,
WHICH IS 46 HOURS OF HANDS-ON
ORGANIZING FOR $2,088.
SO, YOU DO
THE WHOLE HOUSE.
IT'S OUR NUMBER-ONE-SELLING
PACKAGE.
-THAT ONE IS.
-YEAH.
BUT DO YOU COME IN
AND, LIKE, REALLY, LIKE,
JUST GO THROUGH
THE WHOLE HOUSE?
WE HAVE A WHOLE TEAM.
WE HAVE SIX ORGANIZERS --
WE CALL OURSELVES "LIBERATORS"
-- GOING AT ONCE.
SO, THIS YEAR,
WHAT WILL YOUR SALES BE?
THIS YEAR, WE'RE ON TRACK
FOR $550,000 IN SALES.
THAT'S GREAT.
NO WAY.
LAST YEAR,
WE CLOSED AT $407,000.
WOW.
OKAY, NOW,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT.
YOU HAVE TWO LOCATIONS.
YES.
AND YOU OWN BOTH
OF THOSE LOCATIONS.
YES, MY BUSINESS PARTNER AND I
OWN THEM BOTH.
OKAY.
HOW MUCH DO YOU MAKE
ON $550,000?
PERSONALLY,
MY BUSINESS PARTNER AND I
HAVE PAID OURSELVES BETWEEN
$20,000 AND $40,000 EVERY YEAR
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS
TO RUN THE BUSINESS.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
AFTER PAYING ALL SALARIES,
PAYING ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES,
LAST YEAR WE PUT $25,000
TO THE BOTTOM LINE
BECAUSE WE RE-INVESTED A BUNCH
OF OUR PROFITS
TO GET READY TO FRANCHISE.
ASSUME YOU DIDN'T DO THAT.
WHAT WOULD THE PROFIT HAVE BEEN
AFTER PAYING YOURSELF?
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE BEEN
$320,000.
WE SPENT A LOT ON LEGAL,
GETTING THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS,
THE NEW ENTITY SET UP.
WHAT'S IT COST TO OPEN UP
A FRANCHISE?
$20,000 IS OUR INITIAL FEE,
AND VETERANS WILL GET
50% VALUE PRICE ON THAT.
AND WHAT ABOUT A ROYALTY
OR LIKE --
8% ROYALTY.
OKAY.
SO, BASICALLY,
WE'RE TRYING TO KEEP IT LOW
BECAUSE MY TARGET MARKET
IS VETERANS.
I'M VERY AWARE
THAT MY TARGET MARKET
MAY NOT COME WITH A LOT OF CASH
TO THE TABLE.
AND SO I PUT UP EITHER $10,000
OR $20,000, RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
THAT'S TO YOU, RIGHT?
YES.
WHAT IS MY CAP--
TO THE FRANCHISE.
SO, I WANT TO OPEN ONE UP
IN DALLAS.
WHAT OTHER OUT-OF-POCKET
EXPENSES AM I GONNA HAVE?
WE REQUIRE $5,000 IN MARKETING
TO OPEN UP THE CITY.
I GIVE YOU $25,000 TO GET
IN YOUR PROGRAM --
$20,000 PLUS THE $5,000
FOR MARKETING.
HOW MUCH MONEY WILL I MAKE
THE FIRST YEAR?
THE FIRST YEAR,
YOU'LL MAKE $30,000.
I GIVE YOU $25,000,
I MAKE $30,000,
IF EVERYTHING GOES WELL.
I HAVEN'T --
HOW -- HOW DO I LIVE?
WITH ME TRAINING THEM,
WITH OUR SYSTEMS,
WITH ALL OF OUR MARKETING,
WITH EVERYTHING WE HAVE
IN PLACE,
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO MAKE MORE.
HOWEVER, I'M GONNA STAY
CONSERVATIVE
AND SAY YOU'RE PROBABLY
ONLY GONNA MAKE $30,000
SO THAT THEY DON'T PUT THEIR
FAMILY IN A BAD SITUATION.
IS THE $150,000 FOR 20%
OF THE OVERALL COMPANY
OR JUST YOUR
FRANCHISEE COMPANY?
YOU WOULD GET 20%
OF BOTH COMPANIES.
DO I GET 20%
OF THE DISTRIBUTIONS
LIKE YOU
AND YOUR PARTNER GET?
ABSOLUTELY.
MY MAIN
EXIT STRATEGY --
FOR YOU TO
GET YOUR MONEY BACK,
I ONLY HAVE TO DO TWO THINGS
REALLY WELL.
I NEED TO SELL 150 FRANCHISES
AT $20,000 A POP,
AND I NEED TO MAKE SURE 90%
OF THOSE FRANCHISES
ARE WILDLY SUCCESSFUL.
SO, THE R-- THE ROYALTIES COME
ON THE BACK END.
YOU REALIZE HOW DIFFICULT
THAT IS, RIGHT?
-THAT'S VERY HARD.
-THAT IS REALLY HARD.
-THAT WAS A --
-IT'S DIFFICULT FOR CIVILIANS.
I LOVE THAT YOU KNOW
YOUR NUMBERS, THOUGH.
[ LAUGHS ]
IF WE DECIDE TO SELL,
THEN WE SELL AND CASH OUT,
OR WE LIVE OFF THE CASH COW
THAT I AM CREATING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I LOVE YOUR -- YOUR CERTAINTY.
WHAT IF YOU DIDN'T
FRANCHISE?
WHAT IF YOU JUST TOOK
YOUR BUSINESS
AND CONTINUED TO GO THE WAY
THAT YOU WERE GOING?
IT'S JUST NOT FUN.
Herjavec: I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE A PROBLEM
TO GET PEOPLE TO GIVE YOU
A CHECK FOR 25 GRAND.
WHY NOT SIMPLY BRING THEM
INTO THE PROGRAM?
LORI WANTS TO BE
A FRANCHISEE.
INSTEAD OF HER GIVING YOU
A CHECK DAY ONE FOR $25,000,
YOU GET HER GOING.
SHE OWES YOU THE $25,000,
BUT SHE SIMPLY PAYS IT
AT PORTION OF THE ROYALTY.
YOU JUST CREDIT -- YEAH.
THE MORE PEOPLE THAT ARE
REPLICATING YOU,
THE MORE MONEY
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE.
BUT YOU'RE NOT THERE TODAY.
I MEAN, I WISH YOU ALL
THE BEST, BUT...
THANK YOU, ROBERT.
...I-I CAN'T GET
THERE TODAY.
-OKAY.
-I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
ANGELA, YOU ARE SO REMARKABLE
AT DOING THIS JOB --
HIRING THE RIGHT PEOPLE,
ORGANIZING THEM,
ACQUIRING CUSTOMERS.
YOU'RE -- YOU'RE A TORNADO.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND
OTHER PEOPLE LIKE YOU
TO BE SUCCESSFUL
IN OTHER MARKETS,
AND I THINK THAT'S GONNA BE
VERY HARD TO DO.
FRANCHISORS WANT A DREAM THAT
THEY'RE GONNA OPEN A SUB SHOP
FOR $100,000 AND MAKE $1 MILLION
THE FIRST YEAR.
THEY DON'T ALWAYS MAKE IT,
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY IN THIS BUSINESS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM I'M HAVING
WITH IT.
BUT I DON'T THINK THE FRANCHISE
DEAL'S GONNA WORK.
I'M SORRY. I'M OUT.
OKAY.
THANK YOU, MR. WONDERFUL.
I THINK THAT I HAVE SOME OF
THOSE SAME CHALLENGES,
THAT IT COSTS A LOT TO GET
INTO THE BUSINESS
AND THERE'S NO GUARANTEES.
YEAH.
SO I AM ABSOLUTELY A CUSTOMER,
BUT I'M -- I CAN'T BE PART
OF THE BUSINESS. I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU, DAYMOND.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: ANGELA,
WHEN SOMEONE ASKS YOU,
"WHY DON'T YOU JUST
GROW IT YOURSELF?"
YOU SAY THAT'S NOT VERY FUN.
WELL, IT'S MORE FUN TO HAVE A
BIG TEAM AND DO BIG THINGS...
WELL, EXACTLY.
...'CAUSE IN THE MILITARY,
WE HAVE BIG OPERATIONS
AND BIG TEAMS, AND IT'S --
EXACTLY. THAT'S THE SCARIEST
ANSWER YOU CAN --
IT'S MORE EXCITING.
THAT'S THE SCARIEST ANSWER
YOU CAN GIVE ME.
IT REALLY IS --
BECAUSE THERE'S ALWAYS
GONNA BE SOMETHING
MORE EXCITING.
THERE'S ALWAYS GONNA BE
SOMETHING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN JUST GRINDING IT OUT.
AND YOU THINK MANAGING
FRANCHISEES IS GONNA BE EASIER.
-[ CHUCKLES ]
-IT'S NOT.
I KNOW IT'S NOT GONNA BE EASY.
IT'S GONNA BE WORSE
'CAUSE THEY HAD THEIR
LIFE SAVINGS ON THE LINE.
RIGHT.
I THINK WHAT YOU'VE DONE
IS NOBLE, RIGHT?
THANK YOU.
TRYING TO HELP VETS --
THAT'S GREAT.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE
UNDERESTIMATING
THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT'S
GOING TO BE INVOLVED
RUNNING A FRANCHISE ORGANIZATION
AND GROWING IT.
OKAY.
AND SO I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU, MARK.
APPRECIATE THAT.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
LISTEN, ANGELA,
YOU DO WOMEN PROUD.
YOU'VE DONE AMAZING THINGS.
WHEN I STARTED MY BUSINESS,
I STARTED WITH ONE
EARRING ORGANIZER.
YES, I KNOW --
FOR YOUR MOM.
AND I'VE -- I HAVE MADE A CAREER
ON ORGANIZERS.
BUT I DON'T AGREE
WITH THE FRANCHISING.
I THINK YOU COULD GROW THIS
INTO SOMETHING VERY LUCRATIVE
FOR YOU
IF YOU KEEP IT SMALLER.
BE THE ONLY ONE
IN YOUR REGION,
AND YOU COULD BRING IN
A LOT OF MONEY.
BUT ONCE YOU START GOING
INTO THAT FRANCHISING MODEL,
YOU'RE GONNA SPREAD YOURSELF
SO THIN.
YOU'RE GONNA BE RELYING
ON A LOT OF PEOPLE,
AND I THINK IT'S GONNA BE
A LOT OF HEADACHES.
OKAY.
SO, THE REASON I'M OUT
IS BECAUSE I HAVE A DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION
AS TO WHERE I THINK YOU SHOULD
BE GOING WITH THE COMPANY.
GOOD POINT.
THANK YOU, LORI.
AND I WISH YOU GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
YOU ARE ALL FIVE-STAR GENERALS
TO ME, AND I SALUTE YOU.
-THANK YOU.
-AWW.
Cuban: CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR SUCCESS, ANGELA.
Grenier: WE SALUTE YOU.
YOU'RE AMAZING.
THANK YOU.
-SHE IS.
MY TIME IN THE TANK IS NOT
GONNA DERAIL MY EFFORTS
TO FRANCHISE MAJOR MOM
BECAUSE I WANT TO HELP VETERANS
HAVE SOME DIGNITY
WHEN THEY COME HOME
AND PUT THEM BACK TO WORK.
I WANT TO HELP ORGANIZE AMERICA,
AND I'M JUST GONNA KEEP GOING
ONWARD AND UPWARD
UNTIL I BECOME A NATIONAL BRAND.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A BUSINESS
THAT SEEKS TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
SURVIVING IN WAR-TORN
AND VOLATILE ENVIRONMENTS.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS MATT GRIFFIN.
PLEASE CALL ME "GRIFF."
I'M DONALD LEE.
CALL ME "LEE."
WE'RE COMBAT FLIP FLOPS...
[ CHUCKLES ]
...AND WE'RE SEEKING $150,000
FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO ENLIST YOU
INTO THE UNARMED FORCES.
WHAT WE DO IS SIMPLE --
WE MAKE COOL PRODUCTS
IN DANGEROUS PLACES.
IN OUR PAST LIVES,
GRIFF AND I WERE ARMY RANGERS.
OUR MOTTO STATES,
"RANGERS LEAD THE WAY."
OOH RAH.
OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
BADASS PRODUCTS
BY SKILLED ENTREPRENEURS
SURVIVING IN AREAS OF CONFLICT.
THIS MISSION PROVIDES PEACEFUL,
SUSTAINABLE CHANGE
IN AREAS THAT NEED HOPE.
OUR FOOTWEAR IS MADE
IN BOGOTá, COLOMBIA.
WE SUPPORT CRAFTSMEN,
NOT CARTELS.
OUR BELTS, SARONGS, SCARVES,
AND CASHMERE
ARE MADE IN AFGHANISTAN.
WE EMPLOY WOMEN AND PUT
LITTLE GIRLS IN SCHOOL.
WE PARTNER WITH
A DE-MINING ORGANIZATION IN LAO
TO MAKE A LINE OF JEWELRY
OUT OF LAND MINES.
SHARKS, RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE
PROBABLY THINKING WE'RE CRAZY.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT SOMEBODY PROBABLY SAID
THE SAME THING TO YOU ONCE,
AND IT DIDN'T STOP YOU.
WE KNOW THAT BUSINESSES ARE
MORE POWERFUL THAN BULLETS.
SO, SHARKS, ENLIST IN
THE UNARMED FORCES TODAY.
WE BROUGHT YOU SOME GEAR
FROM COLOMBIA, AFGHANISTAN,
AND LAO.
THESE ARE FOR YOU.
I LOVE FLIP-FLOPS.
ROBERT, WE GOT YOU THE --
THE AK-47s.
THESE ARE REALLY
COMFORTABLE.
THESE ARE BEAUTIFULLY MADE.
Cuban:
WHERE'D YOU GUYS SERVE AT?
WE SERVED WITH
THE 2nd RANGER BATTALION,
75th RANGER REGIMEN.
WHERE?
WE DID TWO TOURS
IN AFGHANISTAN TOGETHER.
I DID ONE TOUR IN IRAQ.
AND DID YOU START
THE BUSINESSES THEN?
WE -- WE HAD ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT
STARTING A BUSINESS TOGETHER,
RIGHT, AND -- AND JUST,
THROUGH OUR EXPERIENCES
IN AFGHANISTAN,
WE -- YOU KNOW, WE FOUND
THAT WE WANTED TO DO MORE
FOR THE COUNTRY OTHER
THAN GO OVER THERE AND
BE SOLDIERS, RIGHT?
WE WANTED TO
KIND OF GIVE BACK.
AND WE --
AND WE THANK YOU FOR THAT.
SO -- SO, I'M GONNA SPECULATE
THAT THESE ARE
YOUR BIGGEST SELLERS.
THEY ARE.
WHAT DOES IT COST YOU
TO MAKE THEM
AND WHAT DO THEY COST LANDED,
AND THEN WHAT DO YOU SELL
THEM FOR HERE?
SO, OUR FULL-LEATHER MODELS --
THE AK --
THOSE WILL COST US
$20 TO MAKE.
AND RIGHT NOW THEY COST US
$4.90 TO LAND EACH.
SO RIGHT AROUND $25 BECAUSE
WE'RE AIR-SHIPPING THEM IN.
WHY ARE YOU AIR-SHIPPING?
WELL, BECAUSE
WE JUST HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO KEEP UP
WITH DEMAND.
WE WERE SELLING THEM AS FAST
AS WE HAD THEM.
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS,
WE'VE BEEN SOLD OUT OF PRODUCT.
WHAT -- WHAT DO YOU
SELL THEM FOR?
WHAT WILL YOU SELL THEM
FOR? YES.
WE'RE SELLING THEM
FOR $70.
WHERE WERE YOU
SELLING THEM THROUGH?
LAST YEAR,
WE HAD 89% ONLINE,
DIRECT THROUGH OUR WEBSITE,
AND 11% THROUGH WHOLESALERS.
WHAT ARE YOUR TOTAL SALES,
GRIFF?
LAST YEAR,
WE DID $134,000,
AND WE JUST ECLIPSED
LAST YEAR'S NUMBERS.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA HIT
$300,000.
WILL YOU MAKE MONEY THIS YEAR?
WE'RE ALREADY MAKING MONEY
THIS YEAR.
HOW MUCH YOU MAKING?
WE'RE GONNA BE AT 5% NET
THIS YEAR.
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH VARIOUS
DIFFERENT TERRITORIES,
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHALLENGES,
YOU KNOW?
I REMEMBER WE OPENED A FACTORY
IN AFRICA,
AND WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
THE WORKERS HAD -- HAD BIKES.
IT TOOK ABOUT A YEAR
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE CHALLENGES WERE.
SO I KNOW THAT THOSE ARE
GONNA BE COMPLICATED.
NOW, WITH THAT BEING SAID,
WILL YOU BE ABLE
TO SCALE THIS ACCORDINGLY
AND TO PROVIDE FOR PEOPLE
WHEN THEY WANT IT?
WE BELIEVE SO.
WE DON'T KNOW
HOW TO SCALE,
WE'LL BE VERY HONEST
ABOUT IT.
BUT WE GOT GUYS WHO DO.
HEY, I'M A HUGE, HUGE,
HUGE BELIEVER
IN BUSINESS OVER BULLETS,
AND IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
ANY IMPACT
ON THE REST OF THE WORLD,
WE GOT TO EXPORT
THE AMERICAN DREAM.
SO, YOU SAID YOU WERE MAKING
SOMETHING IN AFGHANISTAN.
GIVE ME THE SCOOP.
SO, WE FOUND A WOMAN-OWNED
FACTORY,
AND WE SAID, "HEY,
CAN YOU MAKE SOME SARONGS?"
AND THEIR FIRST QUESTION WAS,
YOU KNOW, "WHAT'S A SARONG?"
YOU'RE TRYING TO TALK ABOUT
BEACHWEAR TO AFGHAN WOMEN,
AND THEY DON'T KNOW.
SO, WE HAD TO --
I'M STILL SHOCKED THEY LET
AN AFGHANI WOMAN OPEN A --
OPEN A BUSINESS
AND HAVE A FACTORY.
HER NAME'S
HASSINA SHERJAN.
AND SHE LEFT AFGHANISTAN
WITH HER FAMILY,
AND SHE WAS EDUCATED
IN AMERICA.
AND SHE HEARD THAT AFGHAN WOMEN
WERE BEING PERSECUTED.
SO SHE FLEW BACK.
IN THE MID '90s,
SHE FUNDED UNDERGROUND,
CLANDESTINE SCHOOLS
FOR GIRLS...
WOW.
...DURING THE YEARS
OF THE TALIBAN.
NOW SHE'S MANAGING ALL
THE SECONDARY EDUCATION
FOR AFGHAN WOMEN.
SHE'S TAKEN THE MONEY
FROM THE FACTORY
THAT SHE'S MAKING
AND EDUCATING?
YEAH,
AND WE'RE MATCHING HER.
THAT'S AMAZING.
FIRST OF ALL,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
I'M CHALLENGED
WITH HOW YOU SCALE THIS
WITH SO MANY PRODUCTS.
LOVE YOUR BACKGROUND.
LOVE THE DISCIPLINE.
NOBODY HAS DISCIPLINE
LIKE VETS.
BUT IT'S TOO MANY PRODUCTS
FOR THE SIZE YOU ARE.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE NARROW,
AND YOU'VE GOT TO BE VERY DEEP.
OR IT'S A PERSONAL CAUSE,
WHICH IS FINE.
BUT THE CHALLENGE IS, ROBERT,
IF THEY GO NARROW AND DEEP
ON THIS PRODUCT,
THEN THEY WILL BE ABANDONING
A LOT OF THE TERRITORIES
THEY'RE HELPING THAT DOESN'T
MAKE THIS PRODUCT.
BUT THE REALITY
OF THE SITUATION --
YOU'RE ASKING FOR $150,000
FOR 10% OF THE COMPANY.
YOU'RE GIVING A VALUE OF
$1.5 MILLION ON THE COMPANY.
AND WE HAVE TO, AT THIS POINT,
ADDRESS THAT, TO SOME EXTENT.
WE JUST SIGNED
A CANADIAN DISTRIBUTOR
THAT'S SELLING
INTO 390 STORES.
WE JUST OPENED IN NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE MILITARY EXCHANGES.
-WHICH PRODUCTS?
-YEAH, WHICH --
THEY'RE GONNA BE BUYING
THE FOOTWEAR.
Herjavec: JUST THE FOOTWEAR?
JUST THE FOOTWEAR IS WHAT
WE'RE GONNA FOCUS ON.
O'Leary: I THINK WHAT YOU GUYS
ARE DOING IS REALLY --
IT'S GOOD AND IT'S NOBLE
AND IT'S THE RIGHT THING.
BUT THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF THE BUSINESS HERE --
THE DIVERSIFICATION YOU'VE PUT
INTO YOUR MODEL
ADDS A LOT OF
OPERATIONAL LOGISTICS RISK.
I MEAN,
SUPPLYING THESE PRODUCTS
FROM DIFFERENT PLACES
IS HARD ENOUGH.
I WOULD HAVE PREFERRED
TO SEE A --
A MYOPIC FOCUS
ON THE FOOTWEAR,
TO BUILD IT UP TO A $5-MILLION,
$10-MILLION BUSINESS
AND, WITH THE PROFITS
FROM THAT,
SUPPORT ALL THESE
OTHER INITIATIVES
YOU WANT TO DO
BECAUSE, IN THE END,
A BUSINESS HAS TO MAKE MONEY
TO SURVIVE
AND KEEP ALL THE PEOPLE
EMPLOYED,
WHICH IS WHAT YOU GUYS
WANT TO DO.
I'M FINDING THE DEAL
TOO DIVERSIFIED
AND NOT FOCUSED ENOUGH, IN TERMS
OF BEING AN INVESTMENT.
SO, FOR ME, I'M OUT.
I GOT SOMETHING FOR YOU,
KEVIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WHAT IS THAT?
IT'S HOW WE MARK THE DEAD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH!
WOW.
I LOVE IT.
-I LOVE THAT.
-I LOVE IT.
I SHOULD GIVE YOU AN OFFER
JUST FOR THAT.
COOL.
Herjavec: GRIFF,
YOU HAVE A GREAT STORY,
YOU HAVE A GREAT BRAND,
BUT IT'S TOO MANY PRODUCTS
FOR THIS SIZE.
IT'S GONNA BE CHALLENGING
TO KEEP GROWING.
I'M OUT.
PLEASE DON'T GIVE ME
AN ORANGE THING.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
NO, WE'RE GOOD.
Grenier:
I LIKE THE MISSION.
I LOVE WHAT YOU'VE DONE
FOR SERVING OUR COUNTRY.
VERY DIFFICULT TO DO
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I KNOW THAT.
I THINK DAYMOND KNOWS THAT, TOO.
I DO AGREE
WITH THE OTHER SHARKS
ABOUT FOCUSING IN ON SOMETHING
THAT'S YOUR STRENGTH,
LIKE THE FLIP-FLOPS,
THEN BRANCHING OUT,
IS SMARTER, TO ME.
IF ANOTHER SHARK
WILL GO IN WITH ME...
I'D BE WILLING TO MAKE YOU
AN OFFER.
WHAT WOULD YOU OFFER?
I'D LIKE TO HEAR
IF SOMEONE ELSE
IS INTERESTED IN GOING IN
WITH ME,
IF MARK OR DAYMOND IS.
THEN THAT WOULD JUST
BE 200K FOR 25%.
MARK? DAYMOND?
WE'RE HAVING A CONVERSATION
OVER HERE.
OH.
I WANTED TO SEE
IF EITHER OF YOU
WERE INTERESTED IN COMING IN
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW
WHERE YOUR HEADS ARE AT.
YEAH. UH, I THINK MARK --
MARK WANTED TO GIVE
SOME THOUGHTS RIGHT HERE.
YOU WANT ME TO SAY IT?
YEAH.
OKAY.
[ LAUGHS ]
YOU CAN -- YOU CAN SAY IT.
LOOK,
WE'RE BOTH BIG BELIEVERS.
I MEAN, BUSINESS OVER BULLETS
EVERY DAY.
SO, WHILE FROM A PURELY
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE,
FOCUSING, YOU KNOW,
ON YOUR CORE PRODUCT
WOULD MAKE PERFECT SENSE,
THERE'S A BIGGER PICTURE HERE.
YOU'VE GOT TWO STORIES
GOING ON,
ONE IN THE -- THE --
THE FOOTWEAR,
ONE WITH THE SARONGS OR WHATEVER
THE HECK THESE ARE CALLED.
WE -- WE WANT -- WHATEVER
YOU'RE MAKING IN AFGHANISTAN,
WE WANT TO MAKE MORE
OF IT, RIGHT?
WE WANT TO HIRE
MORE PEOPLE.
WE WANT MORE PEOPLE
TO BE EDUCATED.
SO HERE'S THE OFFER.
YOU ASKED FOR 150K FOR 10%.
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO IS GIVE YOU
200K, BUT FOR 25%.
SO, DAYMOND'S WILLING TO LET ME
IN ON THAT OFFER.
WE'RE SPLITTING IT THREE WAYS.
NO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
LIKE HE SAID, LORI,
WE DON'T WANT YOU.
THIS IS 12.5%,
12.5% OVER HERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO
PUT UP ANY CASH,
AND YOU GET TO PICK
ANY OF THE PRODUCTS
THAT YOU FEEL WORK
FOR YOUR OUTLETS.
AND WHAT DO I MAKE
FROM THAT?
-YOUR MARKUP.
-YOUR MONEY, YOUR MARKUP.
JUST ON THOSE PRODUCTS.
I WOULD RATHER BE A PARTNER
WITH YOU.
I THINK THE BUSINESS NEEDS
A FEMININE TOUCH, GUYS.
-NO!
-THANK YOU.
WE'RE PUTTING WOMEN
IN SCHOOL.
WELL, LOOK,
IF YOU'RE GONNA DO THAT,
THEN WE'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE
TO COME BACK AND ASK FOR 30%.
WOULD YOU DO A DEAL,
30% FOR THREE SHARKS?
THAT'S A LOT OF --
THAT'S A LOT OF HORSEPOWER.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO UP THE CASH
TO DO THAT.
O'Leary:
WELL, MAYBE THEY WILL.
YOU GOT TO COME BACK.
CAN YOU DO $300,000
FOR 30%?
I'LL DO $110,000.
I DON'T CARE. YOU GUYS?
-DONE.
-DONE!
BUSINESS.
LET'S GO TO WORK.
THANK YOU, SIR.
CONGRATULATIONS, GRIFF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE.
LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU.
-CONGRATULATIONS.
-THANK YOU.
-[ CHUCKLES ]
THANK YOU, KEVIN.
THANK YOU.
-CONGRATS, GUYS.
-THANKS, GUYS.
-THANK YOU, MARK.
-GOOD JOB.
I JUST DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE TOO
MUCH OF THE COMPANY, THAT'S ALL.
Grenier:
NO, I TOTALLY GET IT.
IT'S A GOOD CAUSE.
-I GOT TO TELL YOU, I --
-IT'S A GOOD MISSION.
-I LOVE THEIR MISSION.
I REALLY LOVE
THIS PRODUCT.
-I AGREE.
-YEAH.
[ LAUGHS ]
-WE DID IT.
-IT'S AWESOME.
WE'RE GONNA HELP A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND DO A LOT OF GOOD THINGS.
WE THINK MARK'S GONNA HELP US
DOMINATE THE TECH SPACE
WHERE WE WANT TO BE,
DAYMOND'S GONNA HELP US
WITH BRANDING,
AND LORI'S GONNA HELP
WITH DISTRIBUTION.
IT'S A DREAM TEAM.
RIGHT.
WE COULDN'T BE MORE EXCITED.
YEAH.